just like you know mathematical proof is
one kind of proof among many okay
there's many kinds of mathematical proof
as well okay and I'm going to show you
like I said this there's a lot of them
but I'm gonna show you four of them and
I'm going to illustrate them with these
own boxes in front of it okay so maybe
you being like this is not mathematical
stuff no need to worry about this okay
now you want to pick up your pen if you
have it already let's walk through four
kinds of proof and I'm not on the
strengthen point okay these boxes one
two three four kinds of proof and you're
pretty familiar with most of these okay
the kind of proof you're used to at the
moment is direct proof okay I even
though we might not have called it that
you want to prove something you take a
bunch of properties and theorems in
qualities you know about something right
in the case of mats within your numbers
and geometry in space right and you use
those properties to come up with a
conclusion right so suppose here we go
four boxes I want to prove that these
four boxes from pushed over okay
can I prove that these four boxes can be
pushed over now how a direct proof
approach this well it would look at the
boxes and say look what do we know about
these boxes okay what can be known about
these what kinds of properties do they
have right and then using some of those
properties we don't need to use all of
them we just need some of them enough to
prove what I just said that the boxes
can be pushed over okay so for instance
I might go and weight all of the bottom
and say well I don't know how much one
of these weighs like 10 grams or
something not very heavy okay and then I
can say well you know I know I'm not the
most muscular person in the room but I
can push over masses that are under 10
grams so I can I can push all of these
over I'm using a property that all of
them share right and I can prove
therefore they're all under 10 grams I
can push things over that are under 10
grams because of because I can lift and
so therefore done proof okay and that's
the way direct proof works right you get
like a triangle and you find out what
properties you have about and you prove
something you know Pythagoras theorem
well
that's direct proof another kind of
proof that we're interested in which you
don't use much because it's um it's
tiring not just because of the name
but let's proof by exhaustion now again
you often don't call it that often it's
called proof by cases okay because the
idea is you take all of the things
you're looking at every possible
instance and individually you prove them
you take every single one every
alternative every way this could
possibly exist and they you just do them
one by one so we call it proof by cases
because you often have to divide up you
know there's 50 situations you divide
them up into three different types and
you can prove them each one by one okay
so how would I do it here what would
proof by exhaustion look like in this
case a row four boxes right I go to the
first one they say can i push it over
yes okay okay great one case one tick
and then I go to the next one and I see
you kissed it and so on right proof by
exhaustion in computing terms we often
call this a a brute-force proof okay
it's simply just going through all in
which is often how people break
passwords they just people use common
words if your dictionaries big enough
you just try all the words and
eventually you'll get one all right
number three more a very common one okay
but proof by contradiction okay now as
purify contradiction work what did I
want to prove what did I set out to
prove perform that all of the boxes can
be pushed over okay so proof by
contradiction assumes or considers
rather what would happen if that were
true what would happen if these boxes
actually all couldn't be pushed over
okay then you take that idea and just
like with the first one you consider it
you work with it and then eventually you
come down to a conclusion where there's
some kind of inconsistency some kind of
thing that's impossible
like there's some box and it can be
pushed over and not pushed on
same time that doesn't make sense it's a
contradiction in my argument
so therefore what I thought about before
that they can't be pushed over it must
be wrong
because if I take that to its logical
conclusion it breaks down okay so that's
proof by contradiction there's a famous
one for you know the irrationality of
square square root of two what's great
for three or whatever that's the most
famous one that you guys have to deal
with now that leads me to my last one
which is our new topic for defense which
is proof by induction so if you want you
can put a heading now which is a
mathematical induction it's important by
the way that's that you make any
mathematical induction because it's
something called proof by mathematical
induction and this induction is actually
quite different to induction in general
terms is inductive logic and this
deductive logic in sort of philosophy
and arguing epistemology
but this is a special kind of induction
okay so I work out the length later
how's it work look at my foot boxes okay
now I'm gonna make some parallels to
these two kinds of proof yeah all right
firstly remember I said the basic idea
was you have to make an assumption right
in the case of proof by contradiction
you soon they can't all be pushed over
okay and then you see what happens if
that's the case proof by induction also
makes an assumption but I'll talk about
what the exact assumption is innocent
okay secondly direct proof okay now what
did we what do we do a direct proof we
looked at the different boxes and the
properties that each one hand okay now
proof by mathematical induction does
something similar but it includes
something different which record doesn't
have okay which is look carefully at
this right proof by induction very
carefully considers what the gaps are
between these boxes direct proof doesn't
care what the gaps are doesn't care what
the relationship between these boxes is
right it just thinks about what does
each box have in common what does each
town as its properties or qualities okay
but mathematical induction right
critical of the way it works is the fact
that these boxes have a relationship to
each other
I didn't just put them randomly okay
there's distances between them that are
gonna be important for us to go second
okay so all right that's all this in a
second right or down but let me show you
how mathematical induction would work I
would have a look at these boxes and I
would say look look at all these gaps
okay
now I noticed that the gaps for each one
are pretty short
okay for instance you know one of the
boxes is not out here right it's not
it's not so far away that they can't
touch each other okay so in other words
they're close enough that if I push one
of them over
just pick one anyone okay and in fact
it's very important that it can be any
any one of them okay this one or this
one or any arbitrary one I can show that
because this distance is small enough
it'll push over the next one I'll push
it it collides and it'll make the next
one fall over okay now if I can prove
that if I can show that all the gaps are
small enough that if I push over any
individual one it'll push off over all
the subsequent ones that's pretty huge
right that that means something very
significant about all of them right now
still haven't proved that they can all
fall over I need one more piece of
information let's stuff from this side
because that's that's your left-hand
side if I can prove that pushing over
one of them and push over all the
subsequent ones right and then I prove
that I can take the very first one and I
can push it over I can take the first
one and it can be pushed over I do you
have the muscles to do the 10 grams if I
put those two pieces of information
together then I should be able to prove
that they all fall over right now I'm
gonna put them closer together just to
make sure I don't embarrass myself by it
you know the demonstration not working
okay the thing is cost I say the gas is
small enough can i push the first one
yes they fall cool okay
all of all of that just for that okay
now um how does it work how does it work
actually mathematically and let's stop
talking about boxes
shall we now they don't wanna know okay